- I wanna talk about feeling good.
So you're in a new relationship now
so how are things and what's
your favorite part about him?
(audience applauds)
Because it's important
to find a good partner.
- Okay, well, on paper
it's kind of ridiculous
but in real life, we get along great.
He's fabulous, and I
don't give men qualities
that they don't deserve, you know?
But he's very, he's very
kind, he's very smart
he's very talented, and he's really funny.
So, and I think he's quite handsome.
- That's it.
That's the thing.
Well, all right.
That's the thing for me too, though.
(audience applauds)
It's humor.
Like, I just like
somebody to make me laugh.
I wanna feel good too, you know?
And since you're busy
making everybody feel good,
you want somebody to do
that for you as well.
So I love that for you.
Congratulations. That's awesome.
It's hard enough just
to live in this world.
(audience applauds)
It's nice to have love.
So it's nice to like,
have that in your life.
But besides Sonny, is it
true that you've always found
that older men are intimidated by you?
- Yeah, I mean, if I hadn't
met younger men in my life,
I would've never had a date
because older men just
didn't like me all that much.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like, men, my old...
Well, I have had a couple of boyfriends,
but that were covering around my age and
but they just didn't
like me for some reason.
And maybe I'm too younger.
Men don't care if you're, you know, funny
or outrageous and wanna do
stupid things and, you know,
and you have a strong
personality, you know?
I mean, I'm not gonna.
I'm not giving up my
personality for anybody.
Okay?